hey David which third-party candidacy
would wreak the most havoc on the 2020
election well to answer this question
you sort of have to add for which party
in the sense that if Michael Bloomberg
for example who is polling roughly 13 or
14 percent nationally among the
Democratic primary voters were to decide
to run third party that would be
terrible for the eventual Democratic
nominee because although Michael
Bloomberg was a Republican for many
years in his life clearly in this
election he is on the other side of
Trump on the other side of Republicans
and if Michael Bloomberg ran third party
it would be very good for Trump and bad
bad for Democrats on the other hand if a
prominent Republican were to run third
party that has the potential to hurt
Donald Trump by siphoning off a little
bit of the support for him I don't think
there's anybody really prominent who
plans to do it there were people saying
MIT Romney with his impeachment vote was
sort of setting himself up maybe testing
the waters to see if there's an appetite
for him to run third party against Trump
obviously he can't win and it would take
it would certainly hurt Donald Trump
help a Democrat doesn't seem that Mitt
Romney has even the slightest interest
in doing that and then you have folks
like you know some of the sort of
cultish third party candidates I'm sorry
cultish cultish lower-tier democratic
candidates like Tulsi Gabbard where you
hear people say she's the only one that
could beat Trump she could even beat
Trump if she runs third party now it's a
completely delusional assertion to make
there is zero chance that Tulsi defeats
trump if she runs third party and she
also has no path to any delegates in the
Democratic primary of course but Tulsi
could take just enough Democratic votes
that it hurts the eventual Democratic
nominee now at the same time her support
is so low in the Democratic Party and
she has some appeal to people on the
right that a Tulsi third party run might
equally take away from Trump and the
Democratic nominee and maybe wouldn't
have that much of an effect but the to
answer the question what third-party
candidacy most has the potential to
upend
the 2020 election it's just a matter of
who is likely to move away from either
Trump or the debt the eventual
Democratic nominee towards the third
party candidate that is who is most
likely to be hurt by it now what I want
to hear from you is there's mention of
would Bernie run third party if he
doesn't get the nomination I don't
believe he would he said he wouldn't
would Bloomberg run third party when he
doesn't get the nomination I don't think
he would and he said the most important
thing is removing Trump and he'll
financially support whoever the nominee
is I believe the guy I think that he
will do that who is a likely third party
run that could actually have an impact I
don't know that I can think of anyone
offhand
likely and likely to have an impact of
course if Bernie ran third party it
would almost guarantee it from win but I
don't think there's any chance Bernie
runs third party is there anyone who
really might run third party and could
have an impact on the eventual election
results let me know what you think we
have a great bonus show for you today
get access to the bonus show by becoming
a member or a patron membership at join
pakman.com patreon at patreon.com slash
david pakman show bonus show coming up
right after this